Speaker 1: Senate Republican Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell weighed in on Donald Trump's
Nazi dinner, white supremacist
dinner. Call it whatever you want.
And he had what sound like pretty strong
things to say about what Donald Trump
did. Let's take a listen to this first clip.
Speaker 3: There is no room in the Republican
Party for anti-Semitism or white supremacy.
Speaker 1: That's a lie. Okay, but let's continue.
Speaker 3: And anyone meeting. With
people advocating that point of view,
in my judgment, are highly unlikely to ever
be elected president of the United States.
Speaker 1: So Mitch McConnell here is saying
Trump is essentially unelectable because of that
meeting that he had. Oh, wow. Well, that's pretty
strong words from Mitch McConnell, right? Well,
he also during this same meeting, the same press
avail, refused to answer. Would you vote for Trump
in 2020? Would you support Trump if he were to win
the Republican nomination? I know you're saying he
is unlikely because nobody's going to vote for
a guy who has dinner with these people. But,
you know, if they did, Mitch, indulge us. If they
did, would you vote for him for president? And
Mitch McConnell refuses to rule it out in light.
Speaker 3: Of what you said, that there's no
room in your party for anyone who covers.
In fact, I submit to you, if Donald Trump
wins the Republican nomination, would you
support him? Look, let me just say again,
there is simply no room and there's no.
Speaker 1: Room, but I might vote for him.
Speaker 3: Republican Party for
anti-Semitism or white supremacy.
And that would apply to all of the leaders
in the party who will be seeking office.
Speaker 1: Did you see that? There is absolutely
no room for this. And anyone who holds these types
of meetings in our party is not going to be able
to become president of the United States. Oh,
okay. Would you vote for him for president of
the United States? Maybe. That's essentially
what Mitch McConnell is saying here. So I'm
going to say it again. It's easy to denounce
Nick Fuentes. It's easy to denounce Kanye. It's
harder, seemingly harder for them to denounce
the elements of the establishment who play
coy with these same ideas. And by the way.
McConnell is not the only one doing this. William
Barr As an example, Trump is a threat to democracy
and bup bup bup bup bup bup bup. Would you vote
for him in 2024 if he's the nominee? Well, I'm
not going to vote for a Democrat. Yeah, I guess
I would. The threat to democracy, you would vote
for it. I mean, progressive Democrats, that's.
That's the most dangerous thing that there is
out there. It's all the same with these people. So
don't fall for the mealy mouthed, oh, it was wrong
what Donald Trump did. He should apologize,
says Mike Pence. Well, where were you when
establishment members of your party were doing all
this stuff while you were vice president? Where
were you? That Jewish space lasers and all this
crazy stuff? Silent. They're pathetic. It's easy
to denounce easy targets. They should actually
look inward at their own elected officials.